bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france les efforts pour venir au secours
des sinistrés s'accélère c'est une
véritable course contre la montre
aujourd'hui pour l'aide internationale
afin d'organiser les secours aux
victimes
oui tout à fait le chp principal
est celui de pouvoir faire acheminer
les autres cas les ressources qui sont
les tanks et c'est bien là que nous
avons nous avons trouvé quelques
solutions mais pour l'instant c'est le 2
juin prioritaire pour nous trouver des
solutions d'un depuis l'europe pour au
prince et ensuite dans la zone sinistrée
et comment est ce que vous expliquez que
ce soit si compliqué d'acheminer du
matériel sur place
pour deux raisons c'est que les volumes
sont énormes déjà et deuxièmement c'est
que le coffre au niveau du fret après un
an et a été dit manière exponentielle
sitôt corrige donc c'est les deux choses
principales pour l'instant vous évoquiez
a le besoin de tentes de quoi d'autre a
besoin haïti aujourd'hui
c'est pas bon la trilogie de base pour
l'urgence actuellement c'est bien sûr la
bri
deuxièmement c'est tout ce qui est hélas
hennissements
purification de l'eau et le troisième
c'est un soutien médical qu'on dit donc
c'est les 3 pôles sur lesquels il faut
s'activer en ce moment on évoque les
aura les erreurs qui ont été commises
après le séisme de 2010 aujourd'hui quel
donges et pointe en haïti
je pense que là probablement c'est la
prolifération de demain comme tout ce
qui est lié à l'eau en fin de comptes
actifs donc ça c'est le problème du
moins
là la difficulté majeure que l'on va
trouver sur place en donniez liés à la
fonte et c'est effectivement de pouvoir
se mobiliser et notamment partir sur les
zones sinistrées parce que dia c'était
compliqué en temps normal avec le
tremblement de terre plus haut les
routes vont entrer endommagés et
effectivement les stickers natale du
cyclone nargis green 2 to donc pour
l'instant voici ce qu'on peut dire de
cette situation
le pays est en pleine crise depuis
l'assassinât du président je venais
louise le 7 juillet dernier est ce
qu'une telle instabilité politique
accentue quelques allées quelles sont
les répercussions sur
l'ampleur déjà en portant de la
catastrophe naturelle
l'histoire nous montre que en tout cas
de catastrophe majeure qu'elle est là il
ya une période de grâce au niveau de
tout ce qui est politique pour dire qu
il faut faire quelque chose tout cela et
je pense que nous sommes au moins
pendant deux trois semaines dans ce
texte où le pays val devoir de toutes
manières trouver des solutions ou aux
besoins immédiats des populations
le ressenti que nous avons pour
l'instant deux travers le réseau
principal les scouts haïtiens d'un côté
et une structure lié à ofi de la charité
de saint vincent de paul nous indique
effectivement les secours se mettent en
place péniblement bien sûr mais se met
en place et le travail actuel qui est le
plus important c'est la quantification
des dry évoqué à peu près affectivement
une soixantaine soixante mille maisons
totalement détruites et 70 par tellement
détruites et ça va être bon avec le très
mauvais temps une des priorités c'est
trouver des solutions de hébergement de
ces familles sans abri soit dans notre
détente jeux spécialement conçus pour ça
ou bien ça peut être par de bois de
construction par des outils pour refaire
les maisons les cages plus de 2000 morts
après ce séisme il ya quelques jours est
ce que vous pensez que cette ce bilan
cette catastrophe aurait pu être évitée
d'une façon ou d'une autre
oui non ce qui est compliqué dont les
cdc en profondeur la magnitude et danser
ça a été pareil pour au princiens
dizaine d'années dès que nous sommes en
zone
urbaine à nous n'avons obligatoirement
quelque le japon a vu la même chose il
ya six sept ans déjà dès que nous sommes
dans une belle comme c'était le cas dans
les deux villes principales des cayes et
jérémy obligatoirement des destructions
massives quelle que soit la qualité en
gros du bâtiment
d'une façon générale est ce que vous
diriez que haïti est aujourd'hui tout à
fait dépendante de l'aide internationale
de l'aide humanitaire
j'ai déjeuné général parce que nous
avons fait pour la wii et est ce que
aujourd'hui ça a été excellent accentué
doublement oui tant que fectivement ils
vont pas s'en sert santé déjà ils ont du
mal en temps ordinaire de s'en sortir
elle a effectivement il faut tu une aide
internationale pour donner qui
permettrait effectivement à bien
utiliser les fonds qui vont rentrer il
ya un grand espoir parce qu'elle est
content structures telles le mouvement
crouch qui sont sur place et pas que et
je pense qu'il faut garder de cet espoir
là que que bizarrement dans cette
catastrophe terrible peut-être qu'il va
s'en sortait un peu de bien sur la
restructuration du pays merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation je me
dis que ça président de l'association
sos attitude